joe biden made some big climate
commitments at the cop conference in
glasgow
we can do this we just have to make a
choice to do it
but 10 months into the job his approval
ratings are on the slide
and some are now wondering what happens
if one prominent republican returns
so could the us's environmental promises
be scrapped if donald trump gets back
here to the white house
[Music]
the united states is the biggest carbon
polluter in history
it's a big country full of big cars
air-conditioned buildings and the
economies of some states are heavily
reliant on oil and coal
per capita consumption of energy in the
united states is very high the other
major economies canada and australia are
the two others that are around the same
level but europe has considerably lower
energy consumption and greenhouse gas
emission and whilst joe biden may be
keen on curtailing climate change
donald trump is not so sure my
administration is putting an end
to the war on call gonna have clean call
really clean call
and neither is his party most republican
members of congress do not want to take
strong action on climate change some of
them out now deny that humans are
causing dangerous climate change others
say okay but we
they do but we shouldn't move so quickly
or the government shouldn't play such a
role
joe biden's popularity ratings have
reached a new low he could lose control
of congress next year so it is perfectly
possible that the last president becomes
the next one too
[Music]
[Applause]
donald trump has recently been holding
rallies in key states he's raised tens
of millions of dollars in political
donations and he holds a tight grip on
the republican base
the united states will withdraw
from the paris
climate accord
as president he pulled the us out of a
previous cop agreement the paris accords
opponents argue his record on tackling
climate change
is mixed
back in the united states of course
some of our progress stalled when
my successor decided to unilaterally
pull out of the paris agreement in his
first year in office
i wasn't real happy about that
donald trump has said climate change is
mythical and an expensive hoax he's also
said i don't think it's a hoax yeah i
don't believe it
no no i don't believe it right now we're
at the cleanest we've ever been
and it's very important to me
some republicans argue people in the
party can be persuaded if climate change
is framed as an issue of economic growth
and national security the best wind
turbines in the world are made in china
if the best solar panels in the world
are made in china if america rejects
nuclear energy at a time when french and
other foreign powers embrace it
wholeheartedly america will find itself
a second-rate nation that has lost out
on a multi-trillion dollar global
opportunity to lead the world again
so what could president trump part two
mean for the us's promises on climate
change a second trump term or a first
term of another like-minded republican
uh president
i think would certainly try to dial back
many of the actions that the u.s has
taken
but much of america's environmental
progress does seem irreversible
the automobile industry is going to
continue to transfer
transform into electric vehicles i think
the electric power industry will
continue to
expand the use of wind and solar
many of these technologies are
developing so i think a lot of the
progress we're making won't be stopped
regardless of who's in office
[Music]
you